I had visions of I wanted to start on a
close-up the camera would be mounted on
the side of the car and I'd be like two
feet away from James Gardner and I want
to start on a close-up of him and then a
car would come up alongside I would be
able to pan off the car and shoot
through the front wheel but you know
when I was on in the gym I was usually
either in a helicopter or another chase
car which was I think was a Cobra or
half the time is that the gt40 duty 40
mainly because it would be almost as
quick as the formal one car on those
days and yeah I would say yeah I want to
be chasing this guy all right the other
guys so I would run fairly close to him
and he would be pairing and shooting the
shots every was looking for baba's I
tell you when I was finished with that
those driving lessons I fell in love
with Bob I said I trusted him 100% with
my life and he taught us how to drive
when we would jockey back and forth with
all of us James Garner and and Bob he
just showed us everything we had to do
and I decided that I went out at that
point and I went to Gordon enterprises
and Grant locks and everybody told me to
go and talk to them and I did in Grant's
I told my Wanda head that I could put on
a car race car and that I could pan and
tilt it automatically and grant came up
with a pail co-head that they used for
tracking missiles and Cape Canaveral and
I really respected Frankenheimer because
he went through Carroll Shelby had a
racing school at that time he wanted to
go through a race school I was away free
for my school
and learn what it's really like and he
brought with us the one that trained him
and I was testing the driving for Kelvin
and my cobras and the Ford gt40 just and
[ __ ] Henry came over to me at the end
of it was training me and he said
introduced himself I'm gonna make the
best race movie that you've ever seen I
said yeah I've heard that before
and he said not like those Mickey Mouse
movies that you've seen before I said
okay and he said I understand you're
gonna be testing tomorrow but well the
springs bass playing and would you mind
if I rode with you and I said no I'd be
fine but call Carol Shelby and get
approval cause he called Carol and
Shelton yeah do it so we went up there
and on the way up there he was asking
all kinds of questions about racing yeah
what it was like which of the car and
all this and one of the things you asked
was if you're going through a corner
really fast and you make a mistake and
you go off the road what do you do I
said if they're going through all right
hand corner yeah a hundred and twenty
five hundred and four and somewhere and
you left off the gas stay off the brake
as you go off the road turn the wheel
straight otherwise you'll roll the car
well toward the end of the day around
four o'clock at Willow Springs used to
blow a lot of wind blew gravel and dust
across the corner and we're doing about
170 and this Cobra and we're not gonna
make this this and this could be the end
of my racing career with Frankenheimer
we went off and I did exactly what I
told my we do but he thought Ellen that
I did it to demonstrate it I do not and
so we went off we came to a stop I said
John you okay yeah John are you okay god
damn that was fantastic I never told
them until the end the movie